foreign
these stories with permission but I've
changed a few details to preserve the
anonymity
of the people involved and so the first
one he suggested The Heading was you
made your bed you have to sleep in it
I'm thinking this is a Two Can Play That
Game uh story so we've got a woman who's
interviewing for a job
for which she was qualified and she was
asked if she had been vaccinated against
covid the would-be employer clarified
that while they don't have mandates now
they had had mandates and they wanted to
no uh if she'd been vaccinated
and uh she was offered the job
she turned it down and then telling them
why
said I'm looking for a position that is
inclusive and I want to work for a
company that values diversity
and do not feel given the passcode
vaccine policy at this company that this
company would be a good place for me to
work to experience those values that I
hold so dear
uh and I think that's that's brilliant
uh let's you know use some of their
tools against them right and this this
also fits with and I again wish I could
show my computer here this week
um but I have shown before this sign um
that is at a store in Sellwood in
Portland uh that I have I haven't been
back for a while but I've seen up for a
while including when everyone was being
told you absolutely 100 need to get
vaccinated right now uh and there are a
lot of a lot of stores and restaurants
that didn't let you in if you weren't uh
and they have this sign up and I'll just
read it from my screen it says we do not
discriminate against any customer based
on sex gender race Creed age vaccinated
or unvaccinated all customers who wish
to patronize are welcome in our
establishment
so this is in in that vein
so I would point out that this is The
Honorable Counterpoint to the evolution
of
um freelance
propagandists that's right that if we
take care of those who in spite of the
fact that it was difficult to do stood
up for us you know instead of having uh
onerous mandates posted at their door
they posted the opposite and they
invited people in
um you know we should remember those
people even now that those mandates are
gone
we should recognize them and patronize
their institutions because we want a
world in which people stand up it's a
better world
that's right it stands a good chance of
functioning
[Music]